product strategy conversations are
happening without marketing executives
present and marketing which is really
the place in the firm where the rubber
meets the road in the sense of where the
firm meets the customer for marketing
not to have a voice in those
conversations does it make any sense the
emerging CMO strategic marketing
leadership program is a program intended
to bring marketing back to the table
sure companies have CMOS but those CMOS
don't participate necessarily in the key
strategic decisions of the firm what we
are looking to do with this program is
to retool emerging marketing leaders in
order to be able to serve as that
strategic marketing voice it's so
critical for the success of a firm the
CEOs looking at the CMO to provide input
so that if as the organization becomes a
transform those inputs become relevant
because at the end of the day for an
organization to be relevant they had to
be relevant for the customer
our program has three essential
components the first component is
strategic how do we think about the
firm's strategy and how marketing fits
within it the second component has to do
with the customer and here we have an
enormous depth of expertise at Stanford
on the psychology of the customer what
is it that drives customer experiences
with drives customer decision-making how
do emotions fit in to how customers
decide both in b2c settings and in b2b
settings and the last component is
leadership leading is not just a matter
of having good ideas but it's in being
able to package those ideas so people
follow you here experiencing this
curated content by some of the very top
faculty that the Stanford Graduate
School of Business has to offer really
world leaders in their field the goal of
this program is not simply to give you
tools on strategy and understanding
customers of consumer behavior but also
almost equally importantly to give you
the tools to then carry those frameworks
back into your company what we want is
for our participants to walk out of this
week and say I got some great ideas
about strategy the second thing is I
really got in-depth understanding of the
psychology of the customer how is it
that people out there are thinking about
their products how is it that they're
thinking about the market how are they
thinking about the competition how do we
reach them have the tools to be able to
then carry that story forward within an
organization
you